meine Lieben Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger was war gut im letzten Jahr
nicht viel was wird 24 besser gar nichtx
ja ist so gute Vorsätze am Arsch und ja
ich habe hier schon Friedrich Merz
stehen obwohl der hier noch Kanzler ist
aber wer glaubt denn dass die Ampel noch
langer hält aus ihrem tollen
Koalitionsvertrag können sie eigentlich
Konfetti für Karneval machen
Streit Gezicke keiner gönnt dem anderen
was unsere Regierung ist wie die Assis
im Sommerhaus der Stars nur ohne Tattoos
und Olaf Scholz sagt einfach gar nichts
mehr mittlerweile kommen Mönche aus den
buddhistischen schweigeklöstern um sich
bei ihm
weiterzubilden die FDP blockiert alles
wie so nerviges Kind das nicht mehr
mitspielen will und Robert habe kriegt
allein den kompletten h der Wähler ab
warum das ganze Jahr haben alle so getan
als käme er persönlich durs
Kellerfenster um die unschuldige
Ölheizung brutal rauszureißen voll
unfair so ein ganzer jungenhafter Scham
ist weg hier der Robby direkt nach der
Wahl und heute man möchte ihm spontan 2
€ für ein Eis in die Hand drücken ja
zwei ampeljahre sind 14 Menschenjahre
und die Union hat auch keine Ideen die
schreien nur nach Neuwahlen hab aber
keinen Bock auf
Neuwahlen
2024 wird sowieso das Jahr der
horrorwahlen im März lässt sich Putin
zum fünften Mal als russischer Präsident
wählen ab November frisst Donald Trump
vielleicht wie der Cheeseburger im im
Weißen Haus gott stehe uns allen bei und
bei uns wird die AFD möglicherweise
stärkste Kraft bei den Wahlen in Sachsen
Brandenburg und Thüringen heißt in
diesem komischen Waldgebiet dass ich
warum auch immer Bundesland nennen darf
wird dann eventuell Bernt höcke
Ministerpräsident ein gelernter Faschist
und erfolgloser Sportlehrer der nicht
mal sie ist und kann mir mal irgendwer
erklären warum jetzt auf einmal junge
Menschen AFD wählen bei der Bayernwahl
hatten die den größten Zuwachs bei den
18 bis
24-Jährigen könnt ihr bitte Dosenbier
trinken und rumvögeln wie normale
Menschen in eurem Alter und wieso pöpeln
Leute die 50 60 Jahre jünger sind als
ich gegen Israel kein Haar am Sack aber
mir erklären dass es jetzt auch mal gut
sein muss mit Hitler
tiktok tötet offensichtlich doch
Gehirnzellen vergesst das wahrecht ab 16
wir brauchen Wahlrecht ab 60 aber egal
bald übernimmt sowieso die KI den
Planeten wir haben es lange mit
menschlicher Intelligenz versucht das
lief so mittel jetzt kommt halt die
künstliche Intelligenz keiner weiß mehr
was wahr ist und was gelogen hier das
berühmte kibild vom Papst in der
daunenjcke ist natürlich nicht echt das
war ich
Ostern in Rom ich wollte eine Jacke die
optisch schlank macht mein Vorschlag die
KI wird Bundeskanzler schlechter
regieren als der echte kann die auch
nicht aber es gibt auch ein paar gute
Nachrichten die ampelparteien haben sich
auf einen
Gesetzentwurf zur Legalisierung von
Cannabis geeinigt der Besitz von Gras
soll zu Hause dann erst ab 60 g strafbar
sein 58 g geil der Januar ist
gerettet und eins ist mir noch wichtig
im neuen Jahr ich gendere jetzt und zwar
nur weil Markus Söder das in Bayern
bieten
will ein frohes neues Jahr liebe
Mitbürger innen und natürlich auch
außen
so 35 g habe ich noch ist das nicht
wundervervoll ich wünsche euch noch
einen angenehmen Tag ihr seid wirklich
die besten und wenn ihr so lieb wird
abonniert doch einfach noch unseren
Kanal oder auch nicht ihr seid eures
Glückes
Schmied